hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the deep well
now it's been a while since I found up
since I found any horror game with a
high review and this was an indie DB
with a eight point eight out of it and
didn't get a lot of attention so I
overlooked it and I'm very eager to give
it a try
hello I appear to be down in a well why
I climbed down here I'll never know
cuz I've been hit hit probably pick up
highlighted item by pressing e okay
right then okay there we go use left
mouse to interact red potions turn your
you can drop your item with the right
mouse button use one two three to switch
between your item slots okay current
item is your battery flashlight is low
hang on give me a second would you give
me a second okay press R to recharge
okay there we go if you walk around in
the dirt Wow
come on sanity can also be affected by
monsters in this case just don't look at
them and run for your life okay
shift to run running courage louder
walking reduces your stamina alright
let's go goal is always on the opposite
corner of the maze
oh it's amazed now is it oh hello mr.
heart falling into this well can have
all sorts of weird effects ah why did I
fall into this well I don't know okay
wait where did I come from where did I
go where did I come from cut nice
are we gonna talk about this hello oh
you're a manic any type I'm gonna assume
that you're just a guardian pointing me
in the right direction okay let's go
with that or something nah moving are ya
oh [ __ ] he moved did he move he moved
boo oh and now ah oh shut up lady I just
got into the game don't do this to me
huh is that ten a potion Oh God
why what's that oh is the crack in the
wall why is it behind me why is it
following me
Oh still there still there
wait a minute I just OOP Hey look at
that
that's a cool effect ain't it oh oh oh
okay seems to be some thing on the wall
I don't know is it it doesn't seem to be
still be following me anymore oh hi hi
mr. eyeballs
how are you doing oh okay well this game
just took a turn to the horrible oh hey
look hey look at that
hey - did I won did i just luck out and
win the zombie is a result of a mutation
which caused the time distortion the
zombie was that the zombie was that a
little zom zom okay whatever oh man I
was not expecting this much you know
when you find these indie horror games
like these really anyone's made on Unity
engine or FPS creator or I'm not sure
which one this is made on but your
expectations are lowered and now all the
sudden I find myself really really into
it haha
I do enjoy good organs and hi mister
eyeballs what are you anyway
what are you what are you okay
like my flashlight is going I need more
batteries very soonish
oh hello hey well the magic maze very
answered my boo what what wow wow oh oh
where is it Melissa oh yeah me what are
you oh yeah
I can't rap I am out of run oh we got
away kinda I got up didn't I take my
potion or did I or didn't have a poof
I dropped my potion to get the batteries
okay all right okay oh well that was or
something oh I don't want to play I'm
almost dead ah dead end
oh I don't know where I'm going it said
that what I needed was on the opposite
corner what is that
yeah that's stamina potion I could use
one of those cuz I'm all stammered it
out and what I need is a health potion
can't believe I dropped it right after I
needed it right before I needed it
anyway
I can't even talk words I can't even
move Oh dead ends nothing but dead ends
I was also screaming straight into the
microphone for like a minute I apologize
for that if I blew out your eardrums oh
that's okay
alright now I just need to catch my
breath without sprinting sometimes when
I'm playing horror games I just have a
bad habit of leaning on the shift key
find a sprint but it's good that a
horror game has a bit of control into it
a a horror game and my flashlight is
dying I sure could use some batteries
I didn't want that whatever that was I'm
sorry I guess I only get one request per
level all right all right I'm gonna have
to switch to my camera which is a much
less gooder version of light but I guess
it will do actually it's not bad if you
got good memory I guess it wouldn't be
bad huh
oh hello hi there hi friend are you
doing huh it's got to be the way out
sometime soon sometime soon I gotta be
close to it right I just gotta be I mean
unless the mazes are getting bigger I
was hoping it'd be at this corner I
thought it was going towards but it's
just a blimp blobbin no it's not a dead
end okay all right don't seem oh no no
oh no oh no oh no this is a really cool
feature with the camera in the thing but
it's very disorienting to have to take a
picture and then immediately look down
or maybe if I just oh oh good the floor
has filled with blood oh boy London was
that was gonna happen I was wishing
wishing upon a star is going on why is
this well filled with blood I feel like
I'm going in circles going nowhere well
if you're going in a circle you're going
nowhere shut up I'm Simon I'm the one
talking here oh no oh no no oh no I
didn't know the camera could run out of
batteries would it make sense now oh no
oh how you doing oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no I am so dead
answer
shut up lady we all got problems I'm out
of batteries I don't care if you're
getting murdered this run faster I guess
oh no oh no I do not like this Sam I am
I do not like not having a light source
in the middle of a well with filled with
monsters and blood
oh no Cameron doesn't rhyme once again
I'm in charge here I'm doing the cup I
can't even see a damn thing I can barely
see the outline of the ground I look
down I think I'm losing my sanity
everything's going wibbly-wobbly just
like an amnesia everything's going
wiggly wobbly I think I'm going to die
I'm pretty sure I'm going insane
well this is it everybody I can't even
move forward anymore cuz I literally
cannot see anything it's all blurry if I
do see something oh I'm going to die can
some monster just kill me please end my
torment oh and my story
I cannot if you guys are like I can't
charity I can't see anything either
okay I cannot oh okay you know what I'm
just gonna I'm gonna okay I'm gonna go
back okay good yeah I saw that there was
a lone mechanic in like who I was on
level two good great
shut up lady like I said we all got
problems okay so I'm sort of on a race
against time while also a race against
resources
I can't run too much but I always got to
keep my bearing so I need to go over
there to get to the other corner of this
map which is where they said the exit to
the well is if this is a well I mean
what kind of crazed well is this what I
thought I saw something down there I
thought I saw an arm long is that
mannequin isn't here anymore I'm okay I
can deal with the rest I just can't deal
with the mannequin oh man
my flashlights already running out of
batteries and they won't give me
anything else they won't give me nothing
else oh man oh I'm so boned give me
something give me some
um give me some anything anything
oh man I guess I should expect the
batteries down in the dog in it down in
this well I already had a potion
apparently oh yeah that's the one I
dropped to get the batteries oh fudge
okay there we go
oh okay okay okay don't use it too much
just got to be very sparing on the
camera usage okay all right okay okay
Oh what oh I see what is it what is it
what is that that's a batteries what is
that wait is that like a lighter aha hey
it's a lighter it's not the best light
source but I'll take it holy crap ah if
I could just get something else then I'd
be perfect shut up lady like I said
previously okay I won't tell you to shut
up you just keep on bellowing for as
long as you want mister yeah you do it
oh you sound great man you sounded sound
phenomenal
shut up nurse I'm busy
ah damn it a dead end
oh that's so cool I didn't even notice
it the fire moves when I move that's a
really cool feature there are some
really cool features in this game I can
see that a lot of work went into it and
I'm very happy blade it's very good I
like it a lot oh man but I can't okay
maybe I'll replace this one physically
as a new battery I mean who's who is
leaving these pieces of technology down
here I'm guessing the other people that
went through this place which is weird
that's a stamina potion I don't need
that right now it's awful what did I get
out oh hi was that you oh hello
what is that Oh
Oh Oh I'm going the wrong way
Oh at least when I'm bloody oh wait I
got a potion hey cool
hey there's something on the ground
there [ __ ] all of that I guess I'm dead
I'm so dead I'm so dead hi friend I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead put that on the ground
I'm dead
I can't get away cuz I can't run fast
enough oh it's still there it's still
there is this a dead end okay I hear it
I still hear it
why can you sprint - that's hardly fair
person dies his body and soul gets
separated his soul gets lost in the maze
and body returns as a different
life-form oh so this well is hell or
purgatory definitely not heaven alright
whatever I'm all out of time for this
one but it is so cool this is a really
well done horror game very original
I like well the maze ideas not original
but I mean compared to what's out there
now it's really good I like it oh this
is a great game you guys should play
totally free of course so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see
in the next video
but
nope